starting off this hour is Amber in
Nebraska hi amber how are you I'm gonna
marry you better than I deserve what's
up okay so I just found her podcast last
month and I have been been doing it like
crazy and one of the episodes you were
talking to somebody and you would ask
them about their tax return and that
they're getting a tax return and they're
giving the government too much money
right is there a magic formula or some
way to figure out how many you can claim
on your w-4 so you get the smallest tax
return back there's a formula but it's
not based on the number of dependents
because the IRS tables are wrong of
course okay so that's you you know you
can claim like for instance my daughter
when she first got out of college claims
six dependents she didn't even have one
and it still got her a refund okay so
she still didn't have enough coming out
so that's how bad the tables they're not
mine early off they suck so they're the
way you would do it is one of two ways
the the most accurate way is to actually
do a fake tax return for the year
actually prepare your tax return and let
it tell you exactly what you would owe
in taxes your total tax bill and then
divide that by the number of months and
that's what needs to come out of your
check per month and so if your actual
tax bill is $4,800 then $400 a month
needs to come out right okay and so that
that's the perfect way to do it now if
you last year got a refund
and nothing major has changed this year
you didn't get a big raise you didn't
get big bonuses you didn't buy a house
you didn't have a kid anything like that
nothing majors changed it's just the
life is almost exactly the same then you
could just take your refund divide it by
12 and go into go into your payroll team
and say hey I want to lower my tape I
mean I want to lower my withholding by
that much so you got $3,000 refund
that's $250 a month
guys I need to bring home $250 or more
and as long as nothing has changed from
last year in the tax law of this year to
last year's hasn't changed dramatically
then that would be very accurate you'll
end up basically getting no refund you
might end up $50 off one way or the
other or something like that but if
something's changed you know that's an
inaccurate way to do it because it you
might be hold withholding enough or the
right amount now I don't know so the
point is what they take out of your
check should equal your tax bill at the
end of the year and if they took too
much out of your check you get a refund
if you didn't take enough out of your
check you're short if you come up really
short they'll penalize you for not
having enough withheld and so you can't
do sometimes people go crazy and go well
I'm just got nothing withheld well that
won't work if you owe any taxes because
you'll get penalized then so you've got
a you know you got to work it in but the
the most accurate way is just to
actually sit down with your tax pro or
if you're doing it yourself with
software or whatever and just run it out
as if you were doing a tax return right
now and then that'll tell you what the
tax bill is divided into a you know a
monthly amount withheld from your check
and of course you know if you get paid
every two weeks then you can divide it
by 26 you know how many checks you know
you got two magic months a year where
you get three checks so you got a
different equation but still yeah what
needs to be withheld from your check and
then just walk into payroll and tell
them this amount and if they need to
back into the number of dependents for
you to check that box to create that
amount that's fine
but the number of dependents isn't
actually your number of dependents that
creates this formula because it's well
the tables are just wrong